ciao amici oggi siamo io e jean su wii u
press the button perché non so se
ricordate vi dovevamo fatto insieme sono
anche marco giampiero e oggi era un po
che non portavo buio pesto e button
allora per il buongiorno andiamo
anzi spiega rino che mi ricordo bene
come si gioca allora we played batto da
quello che riesco a intuire è ti propone
una condizione di un qualcosa tipo ti
succede questo ma che succede anche
questo genere sono un auto con positivo
e uno negativo e tu devi accendere 66 ac
accetti entrambe le cose samsca lo share
non prendere un amico ottiene un
miliardo di dollari ma a termine tutti
quanti gli abitanti del continente
americano oppure devi decidere se farlo
o meno è questo lo ha fatto tramite una
volta vede poi ovviamente le traduzioni
sono fatto un po da cani ma chiesa hai
sposato la sposa perfetta e la tua anima
gemella ma ti parleranno a morte i miti
parleranno così tanto che tutti asciughi
muori penso che preme presser è il tasto
anch'io presterebbe essere il talora
pressiamo il tasto ma chi sempre passa
che selena gomez cioè io poi parlato di
motore
leggi le menti ma non posso fare se ma
no ma perché non pressiamo il tas non
pensiamo il tasto chi soffre ma
oltretutto ha idea di che cosa voglia
dire leggere la mente degli altri tutto
sei mesi anche quello del tizio che
passa puoi creare qualsiasi cosa con la
tua mente ad avere un qui superato che
ci vogliono 20 anni per capire come
usarlo ma chi se ne frega si presta
verbo ma si scusa mi creo una macchina
del tempo che funziona e io torno
indietro di vent'anni ma tu ce l'hai già
in cui alto
io penso che fare qualsiasi cosa la mia
mente lo vuoi vedere sì io posso per
diventare il mio corpo completamente
stellato solo se mi concentro
dimostramelo grazie visto ottimizzati
videogiochi del mondo dove smazza non
puoi suonarli quindi non puoi giocare ai
videogames esa riferiro in europa non
potrei mai più giocare di terim
ma non puoi giorno personali neanche
tipo tipo king zelda non puoi suonare e
poi su mano carina milano perché non
puoi giocare o che non può fare niente
esatto come in tutti i giochi di suoni
non li puoi fare allora avrò piange il
cuore perché io cittadino lo adoro è lo
so però è in tutti i videogiochi del
mondo quindi anche quelli che costerà
una cifra eccetera
sì ovviamente l'avevamo capito che play
voleva di giocarli però non si sa mai
che conoscano i commenti tra le più
talentuose famosa amante di tutti i
tempi secondo me sia vicino invece di
usare i soldi per comprare cose devi
usare favori sessuali dipende se vai a
comprare sempre in posti dove vengono
allora [ __ ] esatto cioè esatto o le
commesse sono sempre delle gentili
donzelle dal fascino avvenente perché se
invece devo andare che ne so da nel bar
sotto casa dove c'è una signora molto
gentile ma di 84 anni
eviterei specificando signora pensa se
c'è ahmed è puoi portare la pace nel
mondo ma devi prima sacrificare di
essere stato da qua qua esce fuori io ti
dico già
non lo faremo tutte le tue ambizioni
mondane sono soddisfatte io ho una vita
felice
cresci le papille gustative nel buco le
cure e l'unico modo per rivelazione
togliendo completamente l'anno e non ci
sono feriti
io non so chi scrive queste domande un
giorno vorrei capirlo 51 che un bambino
di 11 anni ho scritto buco del culo
puoi cambiare la tua risposta sul
pulsante che c'era prima devi dire di sì
a tutto il giorno successivo quindi che
ne so tutte le tue cose mondane si
realizzeranno ma possiamo cambiare
quello che succede dopo ma alla prossima
dobbiamo per forza dire di sì se devo
per forza a premere il tasto ok allora
quindi in casa l'unioncamere tipo si
risolvono tutte le due cose mondane ma
diventi dio
esatto brilla lido ok pressiamo presa ma
questa tassa vogliamo quale la
negatività hai la possibilità di vedere
nel tempo ma puoi andare solo cinque
minuti dietro cinque minuti avanti ma
pressione e freire frenata di parma mia
incredibile ragazzi veramente non per
pensa se invece questa saremmo diventati
legali o tiri uno yacht ma deve
diventare vega vegetariano ma
accettabile io lo farei forse no vabbè
che me ne faccio new york non mi piace
troppo andare in barca no grazie non lo
farei
ora è solo un metro da terra bella si è
già qualcosa certo che se io qualcosa
poi sa in cui tifo in metalli quando
c'era talmente elettrificato quello lo
passare gli avanti ragazzo ma il cosplay
migliori disegnata della terra è vero
perché è vero ti metti così e volli
bellissimo si magnifico le scuole e le
università diventano assolutamente
gratuite ma il creazionismo no
mamma mia non finisco almeno di reggere
non orfani cure tue relazioni
sentimentali non finiranno mai male e
nessuno dei tuoi partner si preoccuperà
se sei poligamo ma vale sesso con la
stessa persona cinque volte finirà
sempre quella relazione romantica
incontrare tutti i tuoi ex almeno una
volta la settimana
non ho capito l'ultimo pezzo cosa
c'entrano gli ex è perché chi ha fatto
questa domanda ipotizza che i tuoi è che
con gli ex tu hai un rapporto di schifo
a è una bella domanda
no io comunque credo che non lo farò ok
ok diventerai un mago e andrei ad
hogwarts ma non sarai mai più normale se
sei un mago e vaio gara ma magari colore
che sono avuto il senso gara non mi
piace harry potter ma ci andrà comunque
la finiro numerati tu dove sei stato
smistato tassorosso sempreverde non
avevo dubbi il tuo canale youtube è
guardato e amato da tutti su internet
poi solo guardare video di youtube in
240 pp allora è già così a parte
primeggiare la regia così effettivamente
è già così in realtà io guardo solo
video di mehmedi a dieci anni fa wind
insomma quindi siamo già siamo già la
non devi mai più pagare per il cibo
ovunque tutto il sapore delle banane
belle banale innanzitutto non fanno
schifo
no quello no però alla lunga è
ridondante e schifoso liberamente dopo
un po i 20 allenatori di pokémon ma non
ci pagano che poi le nere sono adattate
di là si comunque c'è se i mariti tu qui
milano diventi una realtà di processi vi
sono delle slot nei box
ok ma irata temi di maria almeno b2 ma è
comunque 22 pokémon in più di chi al
mondo sì sì assolutamente se puoi curare
istantaneamente tutte le malattie
conosciute in tutto il mondo
provate lasciate ancora hd in coma
madonna ma dall'altra nei primati
verranno concessi trenta esigenti non
puoi desiderare altri desideri e il
primo desiderio deve essere dato al tuo
peggior nemico
chi è il tuo peggior nemico
mi appello al quarto emendamento però
negli altri due con cui puoi avere
vendetta
questo secondo desiderio per cancellare
il loro primo sì oppure tipo per
fargliene passare di conoscere la data
esatta della quale morirai e come ciò
accadrà quindi agli occhi dello
shinigami ma non c'e niente che puoi
fare per impedire moda gli occhi dello
sci migani cioè soldato che magari no e
orribile alle 6 quando muori e
bruttissime poi ti rovini la sorpresa di
noi non li spoglia non ci piace puoi
controllare i tuoi sogni addormentarti
quando vuoi fisico devi dormire con
altra persona del tuo sesso cinque volte
palma si che problema c'è devi dormire
con un'altra persona del tuo stesso
cinque volte cioè io che sua settimana
c'è scritto ci volta in tutta la tua
vita di duemila chi se ne frega del tipo
ci facciamo una pennica e romanzi sì ma
facciamo lo stesso a quanti omofobi però
c'erano il recco gli uomini non puoi
fare tutto ciò a cui pensi arte cibo
scritto la musica d'armi sonora giorno
si dormire solo un'ora gelo vuol dire
che quell ora basta è no diventi un dio
ai videogiochi ma per quello già ora
puoi giocare se le modalità cooperativa
con il tuo fratellino sorella e sei per
sempre giocatore io sono figlio unico
puoi mort modificare il tuo corpo come
desideri avoletto mortifica anch'io
a parte la lunghezza delle tue unghie
un potentissimo pensavo dice sara
trovano ladre ma non puoi mai tagliare
teso
facciamo che no puoi vivere in un mondo
immaginario di tua scelta si dovrà
rinascere come membro della specie
dominante in quel mondo
e beh sì è un negativa starò ma non ho
io voglio andare nel mondo di de
l'ultimo dominatore dell'aria non il
film la serie è dominio del fuoco tutta
la vita deve andare nel dominio
nell'area non ho ma tipo in un mondo
immagine alla tua scelta è un signore
degli anelli o harry potter
quindi il signore degli anelli possa il
signore degli anelli il signore ti vuol
dire che siccome la specie dominante
saresti probabilmente unel forse sì
harry potter invece se resti non lo so
si chiama mago fortissimo vabbè
signorelli sarebbe quesito l'ultima
l'ultima puoi vedere il futuro ma non
puoi cambiarlo dipende che cosa vedi
se vedi il futuro tipo la tua morte no
se vedo il futuro tipo a milano
diventerà la capitale d'italia
la svezia si fonde con la finlandia che
me ne frega se fate che stupido perché
puoi vedere il futuro a puoi vedere tu
quello che vuoi decidi esatto dover dire
tipo l'almanacco in editor al futuro
quindi io so che tipo quella partita di
calcio la vince in quel modo non la puoi
cambiare quindi giochi in via partite di
calcio e vinci usa è pd se venisse vi
solo tenerti tantissimo di non guardare
tipo la sua morte dei tenerti tanti sì
esatto
però insomma che cosa abbiamo imparato
tutto questo che la gente ci tiene un
sacco volare ma non troppo in alto dico
che io vi ringrazio per aver visto
ringrazia gian per aver partecipato
avere dopo 50 ce n'è meno nasale
scusatemi se vinciamo la voce nata da
ragazzi ma c'è veramente l's.os chiusi
schiuso chiuso come le uova e niente io
spero vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio ci hanno ancora detto è come
sempre ragazzi ed iscrizioni ci vediamo
da ragazzi
[Musica]